Democrats getting another huge wake-up
call under March to the radical left
moderate dim Senator Joe manchin ready
to ditch his party and become an
independent
I think that the business of politics
hoppy has gotten so so absolutely toxic
and I'm thinking seriously what's the
best for me I have to have peace of mind
basically the brand has become so bad
the dbrand and our brand you've heard me
say a million times I'm not a Washington
Democrat
and as Joe manchin talks about the
Democratic party brand becoming toxic
here's the latest example of the party's
intolerance Liberals are going into a
rage of Woody Harrelson after the actor
Warren RFK Junior presidential Act
uh Brian
um they're very afraid of RFK I mean
he's not going to win but it's something
about him that is annoying this party
it's hard to dismiss a guy who's Robert
his name is Robert F Kenny Jr who was I
think 13 years old when his dad was
assassinated and stood right there so
you can't dismiss him and say he's some
Fringe Kennedy number two is uh number
two is Joe Rogan also really impressed
with RFK Jr who's got tremendous street
cred the big Democrat Joe Rogan well he
voted for Bernie Sanders uh so but he's
all over the place I mean the guy that
was said I'd never vote for Donald Trump
now says I'll probably interview him so
Joe Rogan's power can't be
underestimated and then with Woody
Harrelson situation that's one of the
most likable guys you'll ever meet
number two is he already shocked people
with an SNL Monologue and number three
is why can't he make his own decisions
we're past canceled culture I'm telling
you we've turned the page you're not
going to cancel people about because of
who they support I'm telling you we
America is moved on and uh and good luck
with trying to marginalize that guy that
guy can act uh Woody Harrelson Jessica
but to Brian's Point why is the party so
dismissive of people that agree with you
all on 90 of the things but feel like
there needs to be a different direction
I mean it's kind of like the same for
black men like typically used to be the
base with Democrats and they're saying
look you're not caring about issues that
matter to us it's like oh no no no we
still got the black women what is it
about that or Joe Rogan he's really not
a Democrat he's a socialist Democrat
it's like he agrees with you guys on 80
of the things why not try to retain
those voters I want every possible vote
that's available we'll take anybody
and that's what happened in 2020 there
were a lot of people voted for Donald
Trump who came over and voted for Joe
Biden welcome you with open arms and I
hope that RFK Junior supports Joe Biden
whose name is going to be on that ballot
and that Joe Rogan makes a good choice
and also votes for Joe Biden there
what I'm saying about RFK when I raise
like you're going on Joe Rogan's show is
that RFK Jr is not running the campaign
of a man who's serious about winning the
Democratic nomination he's serious about
getting a lot of clicks a lot of press
hits but he's hanging out with people
who do not speak to the Democratic base
and doing interviews with them he's
talking about issues that are certainly
important but are not top of the list
for us I think the border is extremely
important but when you look at the
priorities for Democratic voters the
economy talking about the Dobbs ruling
climate change and he's filming himself
down in Arizona that's not going to get
it done for us also he doesn't agree
with 90 of our platform what's gone on
with him over Decades of being anti-vaxx
that has caused his family an incredible
amount of hurt and discomfort and
difficulty that they've had to come out
against him Time After Time After Time
and Woody Harrell said a lot of it no no
he wasn't he said that more people died
they said they they have no interest in
interviews they probably had rules about
it that for instance he would get fact
checked like if it brought up for
instance that there's water that turns
uh kids trans because of some study with
frogs
um or whatever other kooky thing he has
and we've had a lot of people on her
network Byron York has said it's a
complete crackpot in terms of these
beliefs it's really a betrayal of the
Kennedy brand and I think when he hangs
out at 14 15 years that's the problem
with the Kennedy brand about Ted Kennedy
of the Camelot brand of it which is what
he's trying to do and also Woody
Harrelson I'm sure his great friends
with Cheryl Hines I wish I was friends
with Cheryl Hines but it doesn't mean
that RK Jr would be a good President Joe
Manson tried to appeal to the Democratic
base that Jessica talks about and now
he's getting ready to lose a seat yeah
so he's trying to distance himself from
the Democratic brand saying that it's
toxic in many many parts of it are very
toxic but this is actually about Joe
manchin's brand when he plays with
becoming a republican in West Virginia
he's about to lose his senate seat Jim
Justice a very popular Republican
Governor has a 64 approval rating there
Joe manchin's approval is only at 40
percent and his disapproval is at 53 and
why is he unpopular because he voted for
the almost one trillion dollar inflation
reduction act which at the time it was
passed we knew was a handout to these
green climate change projects which are
completely corrupt and not actually
environmentally friendly and now the
president is finally admitting that Yeah
we actually named that in a fraudulent
fashion we call it the inflation
reduction act because Americans are
suffering with inflation but now we're
trying to appeal to our climate change
base for an election so therefore we're
going to go back and actually tell
people what's in the bill and that it's
actually a climate change green handout
corruption Bill and so that's why Joe
manchin is saying yeah maybe I'll toy
with this whole Republican thing because
he's about to run for president No
Labels because he might have or that too
but also running if he runs just because
he's losing himself get the judge in
judge if he runs third party is this
good for the Republicans or no
well I don't know who would is good for
to be honest with you I mean Mansion has
kind of danced and straddled the fence a
lot you know the crazy part of it is you
know they're celebrating the one-year
anniversary of the inflation reduction
act and he's not going to the
Celebration when he actually signed the
bill I mean uh supported the bill and I
think he finally gave him the pen yeah
well okay and then you know is he ready
to ditch the party no he says he's ready
to do he the party is ditching him okay
because Jim Justice is going to win
there's no question about he's losing so
what viability does he have the only
viability he has is to run as a third
party no labels candidate okay let's
talk about the Dems I am so sick and
tired of the haters they are haters all
they do is they hate you they began the
unfriending of you anything you do they
hate they want to censor you I've never
seen a party like that and let me say
something about Robert F Kennedy Jr I
know him I was a D.A when he ran and the
environmental program in Westchester he
was respected I respected him he was
very serious about what he was doing a
lot of his family is vaxxed there are
certain vaccinations he's not in support
of and it's too bad if the rest of the
Kennedys feel bad about him the bottom
line is he's doing whatever he can and
when he takes that video at the border
and talks about what is going on he's
doing more than Joe Biden is and Joe
Biden was in in where where was he New
Mexico this week for two days he
couldn't go to the Border Kama is so
ditzy she doesn't even know her job is
supposed to be overseeing the border so
let's get straight about this the
Democrats are intolerant of anyone who
doesn't tow the Joe Biden corruption
line and that's all I have to say about
it but on the other side Donald Trump
had no primary the RNC didn't support it
there were no debates what's this have
to do with the primary please don't
unfriend me
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else